joined by magnus carlsen who just lost
that match to ding how are you right now
magnus
um i'm okay um
[Music]
um yeah i'm really disappointed with my
play in the in the last game uh but i
think overall this yeah this match could
have gone either way and
i played a lot of close matches with
with a thing and this one went went his
way which is
yeah it's disappointing but
that's what it is
and what can you say about uh the way
ding has been playing in this match some
fantastic games by both of you
yeah it's
um
i think
uh we we both
we both made a few mistakes here and
there but we i think we also did
a few things at uh at a high level so i
think it was was a pretty good match
overall um but
yeah i think i had my chance in the in
the penultimate game uh and i didn't
take it and he he took us so
i guess that's fair enough yeah and we
do know of course ding is playing
candidates in a few weeks so
for his opponents do you think he is now
a big favorite in the candidates
no i don't think um
i don't think that's particularly
changed um
because of this
everybody knows
his his ability
absolutely and for you magnus obviously
playing norway chess starting next week
so what is it about for you now the next
coming days
uh we'll see um
i mean
i i'm of course happy about the
opportunity to um
you know
strike back quickly so that's that's a
good thing
absolutely magnus uh thank you for uh
joining us and um
and thank you for all the entertainment
and chessable masters best love luck in
norway chess as well
thank you